you know what let's just let them go
just go hurt themselves right if they
come off of it don't all cats land on
your feet or some or their feet okay no
no no what are you talking about I've
heard this if a cat like false or
something the cat Falls they land on
their feet
oh my god it's on the back I'm a mom I
mom you gotta get it you gotta get it
gonna be fine it's this is how they
learn this is how they learn anyway I
see you guys are very excited about my
film look at this look out TV ready they
are put an album cover right here just
like this is have you ever seen your
setup there's seven guy better fall in
line all right go over there
oh oh you're going all the way around
about your films this that guy you're
crazy I don't want you to die man
so about your films I don't know and
happily Becky and happily yes Becky is
made by a it's a great it's me and a
wonderful actress named Lulu Wilson and
Kevin James it is it is definitely not a
comedy and then the other ones called
happily directed by a guy named Ben
David Griffin ski and it's mean a
wonderful actor named Carrie Boucher and
Stephen root who you've seen on Barry
and a thousand other things radio and
but no one's listened to a thing I've
said it doesn't matter let's do this
let's just move on to the red
oh wait that's mine okay so that's in
April and I know you'll all go there
Film Festival you'll love it wait okay
wait so card sharks card sharks is back
look um
do you like being a game host is it fun
what is a game host a game you're
hosting a game show host games we give
away cats and gonna go great yeah you
can win look it yes it's that you can
win a lot of money I can totally get you
on the show okay but if you think about
it Kelly nobody is listened to a thing
we have said in the last few minute
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going